thank you there was a scheduling um
problem with several of our members
today uh with some count a commitment so
we've shuffled the deck a little um and
um Sue Newman and um representative
Eaton are joining us here today
substituting and uh so we will we'll
continue on with our business um long
range Capital planning utilization
committee um their minutes have been uh
distributed uh for the December 15th
meeting or do anyone note any omissions
or Corrections that need to be handled
at this point in
time seeing none uh do I have a motion
to accept the minutes of December 15
2023 thank you moved and seconded by the
senders uh if you're in favor of the
minutes accepting the minutes December
15th signifi by saying I I any opposed
one one
Oban okay we will move on to uh new
business um disposal of Highway and
Turnpike funded real estate item lrcp
24001 Department of
Transportation request authorization to
sell 006 of an acre of state-owned land
within the RightWay located in the
northern side of New Hampshire Route
27 uh in the town of eeping and if you
would please present for the
Department thank you Mr chairman Steve
leonti with the New Hampshire Department
of Transportation the department seeks
to uh dispose of 600s of an acre located
in the town of eping on the side of
Route
27 for the price of
$10,500 which includes the
$100 administrative fee um to Adam and
Alexa
Tai Syria um I will apologize to them if
they're watching right now better you
than me
sir um the buyers recently acquired the
property that abuts the subject property
at U 193 Pleasant Street in eping it was
then discovered that their driveway
passes over this small triangular piece
uh to remove the cloud on title uh the
buyers contacted the department through
their attorney and wish to acquire this
property the parcel is a portion of a
larger parcel acquired in 1936 the uh
original parcel was 1.38 Acres which was
acquired from Edwin K hod
hodgden um for
$142 in uh for the eping Brentwood
project uh the property was reviewed by
the department and determined to be
Surplus to its operational needs the
parcel uh will be conveyed with the
condition that they do a boundary line
adjustment to be uh planned have it
surveyed to a boundary line adjustment
plan to and um that will eventually be
recorded in the Rockingham County
registry of deeds buyer will be
responsible to obtain all local and
State uh Lan use approvals precedent to
closing closing um it was determined
this the property was reviewed by
certified General appraiser it was
determined that the property didn't have
its own highest and best use just based
on its small size and
shape uh but it was determined to be a
contribut have contributory value to the
abing parcel of $9,400 that with the
$100 administrative fee brings us to
$10,500 uh both the town and the
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority uh
were solicited for their interest and
not surprisingly they were not I can
answer any questions yep questions Mr
Lamonte seeing
none um yep please motion motion to
accept uh made by Eaton seconded by uh
delandro um any further
questions if you're in favor of of that
motion disposing of this property uh
signified by saying I I I any opposed
motion carries
unanimous uh second item item
24002 uh Department of Natural and
cultural resources requires
authorization to amend an existing
easement agreement at no cost to include
the towns of Anum and Bennington public
water supply and wave 1100
administrative fee subject to conditions
specified in the request dated January
10th of 20
four is Mr Shay um there's nobody from
the Department here today I'm not not
sure why um but I think the item is
pretty
straightforward um the issue was brought
to the Department's attention this fall
when the towns the Two Towns mentioned
in the item were starting this um water
supply project and they realized that
they had an easement with the state for
a piece of property that they needed to
cross with the water lines and they just
were looking to get that that changed I
believe the commissioner was in contact
with uh some members of the committee
the chair specifically um last month in
uh December to see about getting an item
put forward to do this amendment and
that that's pretty much the limited
information I
have thank you
um I don't have a um an issue unless
it's a procedural issue about bringing
it
Forward I would like to uh send a
message to the commissioner that uh made
great effort to have this happen today
not to have someone from their
Department show up and at least
introduce it I'm not happy with that but
uh unless um unless there's objection by
the members I would U I would move to
approve uh item
242 under the U the conditions as stated
um in this documentation that was
presented seconded by Eaton any further
questions
if you're in favor of that motion for
the disposal of the property mentioned
24002 Department of Natural cultural
resources signifi by saying I I I those
opposed uh motion carries
unanimous uh Mr Shay are there other
items there informational contained in
our
packets so there's three informational
items there's no action needed for those
items so unless anybody has questions um
you're pretty much done your meeting all
right sounds good I'd like to uh Set uh
we spoken previously setting the next
meeting tenably for well we will set it
for April 5th at 10 10 a.m. uh if it's a
conflict uh uh just please let us know
and we will work on that for the
members um with that and not hearing an
objection to that date at this point in
time um accept the motion for me
seconded by Senator desandro to
adjourn all those in favor signified by
saying I I a opposed it carries un
namous thank you one and all for taking
the TR the time to be here today
appreciate
it